[Music]
hey guys
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter theory like I've done in the past
for Dumbledore Voldemort Snape and
McGonagall I'm going to be listing
Harry's top five most powerful spells
and abilities
Harry has proven himself time and time
again to be competent in all sorts of
situations and as a result has shown us
all sorts of spells I'm mainly going to
be focusing on the spells that Harry
uses often and executes well for example
crucio will not be on this list
even though Harry used it because he
wasn't particularly proficient at it
additionally the order of the list will
be determined by a couple of things the
first being how powerful or complicated
the spell is and the second being how
useful it was for Harry coming in at
number 5 on the list is Severus Snape
spell Sectumsempra though it is not
something that Harry uses regularly it
is powerful and having studied Snape's
textbook for advanced potion making he
doesn't know how to use it
he first uses it on Malfoy Roth
successfully leaving him in a pool of
his own blood Snape rushes to mal for
his side and heals him using a counter
spell
vulnera sanentur the second time Harry
tries to use it is on Snape himself and
as you can guess this didn't go quite as
well Snape invented the spell and knows
it better than anyone so it was unlikely
that Harry was going to be successful
that time
Sectumsempra is of course a vicious dark
curse that acts like an invisible sword
causing lacerations hemorrhaging and
cuts upon its target often after being
struck the target will lay there
motionless as they lose blood again even
though Harry doesn't really use it much
it is in his arsenal it is a powerful
spell and he does know how to use it so
I think that it deserves this spot on
the list number 4 analyst is protego
also known as the shield charm this is a
defensive ability that any witch or
wizard should possess in a magical
Arsenal it blocks physical entities
reflect spells and even rebound conjure
a
back towards the caster this is
showcased when Snape is using legitimacy
on Harry and Harry decides that he has
had enough there are a few variations to
the shield charm including protego duo
which is a slightly more powerful
version of the standard protego
protego horribilis which is the most
powerful version of the standard protego
protego Maxima protego to Talam and
lastly protego diabolica
which Grindelwald famously uses in
fantastic beasts though the standard
former potato is not exceptionally
difficult to learn or cast it is a
must-have and served its purpose for
Harry on many occasions coming in at
number 3 in the list is stupefy stupefy
also known as the stunning spell is a
charm that stuns the target rendering
them unconscious
stupefy should probably be a staple
spell in any witch or wizard's arsenal
Harry loves stupefy and uses it
extensively over the course of the films
and books using it in numerous duels the
Triwizard Tournament the Battle of the 7
Potter's the skirmish at the Luchino
cafe the battle in the Malfoy Manor the
Battle of Hogwarts and many more
instances it's used extensively in
dueling because it doesn't cause lasting
effects or damage but it is appropriate
in battle if you don't want to kill
someone known defenses against stupefy
include renovate and deflection by a
shield charm one thing to note is that
it won't work on trolls Giants dragons
or half Giants coming in at number two
and LS is expecto patronum if you know
Harry you know that he has one or two
run-ins with the mentors over the course
of the film with no other means of
protecting himself against the Mendes
the necessity for expecto patronum was
immense it was a completely invaluable
skill for him expect to patronum
otherwise known as a Patronus charm is
used to create protective shield around
the wizard or witch it evokes a positive
energy force known as a Patronus which
is considered to be the spirit guardian
of the caster harry's Patronus is a stag
just like his father James
expecto patronum is the only known
defense against both Dementors and Natha
faults not only is it massively useful
for Harry it is also quite a difficult
spell to cast Harry learns it at an
extremely young age and eventually
teaches the members of Dumbledore's Army
how to cast it as well coming in at
number one on the list is expel the
armas okay I know what you're thinking
expelliarmus isn't that just a disarming
charm it's taught to members of a
Dueling Club at Hogwarts the answer to
that is yes however is also the spell
that Harry uses to defeat Lord Voldemort
expel yamas is essentially used to
disarm your opponent and strip them of
their wand it's used extensively in
duels that can actually send an opponent
flying through the air if the casting is
particularly powerful so while it is
easy to learn it is exceptionally useful
and has one of the main reasons that
Lord Voldemort was defeated when
Voldemort cast a vada Kedavra on Harry
in the path of Hogwarts Harry responded
with expelliarmus which then sent
Voldemort Avada Kedavra back at him
by the elder ones recognition that Harry
was its true master so while it's not
the most complicated expelling our most
improved to be one of the most
significant spells in the series some
honorable mentions include Petrificus
Totalus
and gore Geo Reducto vineet a Incantatem
obliviate and Guardium Leviosa
Alohomora Accio and impedimenta
and that concludes the video what do you
guys think this this do you agree with
it or is there something glaringly
obvious that I've missed if so please
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
Harry
[Music]